you are looking at Megan Markel the
Duchess of Sussex at the hub community
kitchen in London reuniting with
survivors of the gren fall tower fire
it's always given back she recently
worked with the woman to create the
cookbook all together our community
cookbook to raise money for the kitchen
joining us now live from London is
Rachel mccraty to talk about that sweet
moment and other royal news Rachel hello
a little bit about megan sweet reunion
this morning absolutely so I'm Megan
this Wednesday morning I got a jump
start on her Thanksgiving cooking she
visited the hub community kitchen which
is in West London and met with some of
the women that she collaborated with on
that cookbook you mentioned and right
before the visit they announced the
cookbook has sold around 40,000 copies
in the UK raising about two hundred and
seventy thousand dollars which has gone
towards renovations at the kitchen and
allowed them to stay open seven days a
week and also allowed the women who
worked there to have kitchen safety
courses so obviously some great work
from the Duchess on my first big solo
project as a royal and this is something
that she's held so close to her heart
I did I did read on Twitter one of the
Royal contributors said that she stayed
about 20 minutes longer than scheduled
this just goes to show I feel like you
know how special this project really is
to her right absolutely she looked very
excited she was hunting all of the women
both outside and inside the kitchen
obviously she had been to the kitchen
before though that time had not been
publicized
and then she had invited the women into
Kensington Palace back in September for
a special celebratory meal which her
mother Duryea Raglan was there for as
well so she's developed a pretty close
bond with them and it was just a nice
outing for her today and you could
almost see a hint of that baby bump yeah
right there we we do have I believe
photos of kind of the before and after
of the kitchen during the renovations
obviously you mentioned they've raised
from the cookbook over you know almost
two hundred seventy thousand US dollars
here's a before photo
we'll take a look at the after next but
like you mentioned you know instead of
the kitchen being open only two days a
week now it's open seven so they're able
to you know cook more and you know
really benefit the community yeah we
also know going continue know continue
go ahead oh say so Megan got her hands
dirty and helped prepared 200 meals Wow
they do do their and obviously the
Greenfield tower fire was a very huge
loss in London last year it took the
lives of more than 70 people so that
community is still suffering and
struggling but the kitchen is obviously
a beacon of light for them so it's a
really nice gesture on Megan's part yeah
I would I would agree we hear that Kate
and uh Megan had a little twinning
moment as well tell us about that yes so
it seems that burgundy is the color of
the day obviously but so Megan's stepped
out and she was wearing a Club Monaco
dress and matching coat that were both a
burgundy color and just a few hours
later Kate Middleton stepped out for an
event of her own and she was wearing a
pall cost guard suit that she's worn in
the past she loves recycling those looks
but I'm not sure if that you called and
coordinated colors but they were both
looking very festive and full as they
stepped out in London today so Kate was
visiting a neuroscience lab for her own
separate event but these two have though
they have very different styles have
been known to kind of copy each other a
little bit in the past and clearly have
a lot of deep affection for each other
so it's nice to see that is two out
together and rocking some similar looks
yeah great well you know they do the
same great minds think alike in those
two were pretty sure the next world
they'll causing some buzz Prince William
he really got candid recently about his
mental health the duke of cambridge
revealed at a conference in london on
tuesday he struggled with his well-being
after having children and juggling his
job as an air ambulance pilot take a
look i was several times on very
traumatic jobs involving children
and after I had my own children I think
the the relation between the job and the
personal life was what really took me
over the edge and I started feeling
things that I've never felt before and I
got very sad and very down Rachel this
really isn't the first time that Prince
William has kind of opened up about the
impact being an air ambulance pilot has
had on him mentally what do you think of
William being so candid well the younger
Royals are known for really speaking out
about their mental health
they started the heads together
initiative which of course the focus is
on highlighting mental health and mental
health awareness and so Prince William
has spoken out in the past as have
Prince Harry and Kate Middleton who work
on the hoods together foundation with
him but really I think the family in
general is just very inspirational for
people especially in Britain where a lot
of the time to keep calm and carry on
slogan has they've talked about it being
pink calm and keep quiet
and they really want people to speak out
and let others know that they're
struggling and they've been really
candid with their own struggles harry
has talked about going to therapy after
the death of his mother Prince Diana and
of course Prince William like you
mentioned being an air ambulance pilot
has seen some pretty horrific situations
himself so just kind of opening up about
how important it is as a male because a
lot of the time men are not the ones to
speak out if they're struggling and as a
father to just say you know it was hard
not to bring this home with me and I
fortunately he said he had a good
environment at work where he felt
comfortable talking about that but
really encouraged other workplaces to
speak out and to really help their
employees if they're struggling with
mental health
well Rachel thank you so much for
joining us from London this morning and
have a wonderful holiday absolutely you
too
[Music]
[Applause]